one of the great features of living here
in downtown Milwaukee is getting to see
all of the wonderful public art that
gets posted all over the city and we're
really fortunate this year in that we
have this ornament Trail in downtown
Milwaukee most of which is centered on
Wisconsin Avenue but a bit of which goes
up Water Street as well if you live here
you may have already seen these
ornaments but for the many people who
don't I thought I would share these with
you and I'll just tell you the location
and the title of each artwork who the
artist is and who the sponsor or
sponsors are for these wonderful
ornaments and you can tell I was just
walking down the street taking video of
them I don't think that much more
commentary is needed you can feel free
to leave your comments about which ones
you respond to the most which ones are
the most holiday season for you or the
most Milwaukee if you know this great
City and with no further Ado here are
the
ornaments we begin with those on
Wisconsin Avenue between Valar Phillips
and Martin Luther King Drive this is
snow season by Jansen
rapar and it was sponsored by hob 640
and the bearded
Center then we have P Amore Amistad that
is peace love and friendship by Mauricio
Ramirez sponsored by
310w after that we have DW men Rams
horns by Brad Anthony Bernard with
student assistants Grace grasser Shelby
Smith and Lindsey green sponsored by the
Avenue and visit
MK heading up Water Street we now have
two ornaments one is life has always
gathered here by Jeff zimple who's a
former Saint Kate artist in Residence
and the sponsor is St Kate the Arts
Hotel
then we have the joys of winter by
Rosalia Singh sponsor is Reinhardt
burner fond
Duran and now now we're going to head
way over to the east
side we see on the East End of Wisconsin
Avenue heading west we have Untitled by
the kout brothers sponsored by
Northwestern Mutual and the Milwaukee
Brewers this is right out front of the
iconic Northwest Mutual Tower
complex
heading down the street we have current
pass Times by David Watkins sponsored by
and right out front of the US Bank
Center continuing on down the street we
have Winter's rabbit by Drew York and
this is sponsored by the 600 East Cafe
and Business
Center moving down the street west on
Wisconsin near Jefferson we have winter
Reflections by Josephine rice this one
is sponsored by the Milwaukee Club and
joy
angen next we have leria Holiday by
Nicole a Costa the Fister artist in
Residence sponsored by the Fister
Hotel
then we have Mary and bright in Flight
by John kowalek sponsored by
PNC and now we're moving further west on
Wisconsin Avenue near Wisconsin and
water first we have flourish and Frolic
by Emma Daisy gerle sponsored by 250 and
hntb right across the street we have the
four Graces by Nova
Chari sponsored by the railway Exchange
building and the Colby Abbot
building finishing out this set we have
Mary in Pink by Monique masut sponsored
by Chase Tower MK this is right across
from the Chase Tower so easy to see on
Water
Street
heading up Wisconsin Avenue near James
Lovel Avenue we have Painting the Town
which is by Dave Watkins and you've
heard his name already he actually has
two artworks in this ornament Trail this
is sponsored by Jay Jeffers and
Company
finishing the ornament Trail on its West
End we have this entire set of ornaments
out in front of the library in the
middle of the island of Wisconsin Avenue
so just a little past 8th Street and
this is called the court of honor and it
is sponsored by the Milwaukee downtown
bid
so I hope you've enjoyed these and you
can leave your comments about which ones
you like the best down below and come
and check out this great City of
Milwaukee
that